sometimes i i don't know why i love
doing this i just like search like 2008
conventions or 2010 conventions and just
watch vlogs
yeah from people with like 100 views you
get some of the like
best [ __ ] from doing that because
there's like so much in drama between
these friends yeah
of like like cody left on day two
because he refused to share the bed with
me and it's like it'll be like a hundred
hundred of you vlogging it'll be the
[ __ ] like shane shot in the bed
and i couldn't [ __ ] believe it it'll
be one
like i remember this one time and i cuz
when i i went i guessed at a convention
like indeed
in the uh some indiana convention not
any popcorn another one and this
convention been going on for a while so
i was going back every single year and
finding vlogs of it
yeah and then there was this one guy
from like 2010
and he opens up the vlog with yeah so
cody's not here
you guys know why and it doesn't explain
and for some reason that's so funny i
like mid-2000s conventions i remember it
just seemed like you're walking into
another world
like the rules of like i remember when
just the rules of normal society did not
apply to anime conventions you know
i i tried so far i usually hate watching
like cringe compilation videos because i
just i personally can't stand yeah i
don't find them funny
but the one types of cringe compilations
i [ __ ] love is like the mid-2000s
like
marriage proposals
oh [ __ ] best it's like it's like
watching like it's just it's
boys it's always outside of the
convention center and there's a crowd of
people
all the same cosplayers always it's
usually like naruhina or somehow
somebody like it's always narrow here
now i don't know what it is i think one
of my favorite videos on youtube of all
time is this video called uh 2001 and
anime odyssey oh my god
i remember showing it to them at
christmas and it's just basically a
highlight review of this very old
anime documentary that follows like
these so good it follows these people
at certain anime conventions and like
this was before the mid 2000s it's like
like the late 90s yeah yeah yeah and oh
my god
some of the stuff that was going on
there was what was what was the name of
the dude
johnny o'taken johnny otaku my man
the legend he was like yeah i'm gonna be
a funimation version
whatever though
[Music]
[Applause]
i actually searched his uh searched up
his story after i saw that video
so do you want to explain johnny otaku
to people who might not know johnny
otaku
is one of the most like like one of like
one of the creepiest kind of
self-confident anime fans you could like
you could like ever see one of the most
infamous anime fans the most
infamous the kind of guy who brings you
to a convention is like oh i know
everyone here yeah
so i remember in the documentary he was
like running his own radio show
um that was like an anime radio show and
he was trying to be
a voice actor um that he said he was
saying he was
mother he was he he was he was an
aspiring voice actor
yeah which you know going off tangent if
you i don't know why people use the word
aspiring
essentially like when i go when i go on
a twitter profile and i see the word
aspiring and i'm like come on dude
you can do better yeah aspiring aspiring
voice actor just means i own a yeti
snowball
just say you're just just saying just
say you're a voice actor or just don't
put it in just like one or the other you
know
but yeah he was an aspiring voice actor
and
i i searched up his story after i saw
the video and i saw like this
funimation panel where they they were
talking about this person
called like john or johnny or something
that that tried
so hard to get an audition that they
literally had to ban him
from the funimation officers because he
was like stalking employees and all this
[ __ ]
and then i kind of just connected the
dots i was like
wait a minute there's this guy called
johnny and there's one
in this one video who like really
aspires to be like vick manana
and then there's this another story by
funimation employees who's
talking about this guy called johnny
stalking funimation employees at their
offices
and i'm like oh that's yikes can i just
say
can we get johnny or taco that would be
[ __ ] legit yeah
johnny if you're watching this please
come to japan i know you love this
country just
just come here we'll put you on the
podcast yeah i want to hear the story
yeah i implore the viewers at home just
type in any anime convention and type in
like
two thousand okay vlogs yeah that's so
funny watch 2001 and anime obviously
it's a 30 minute video
but my god it's it's it's so good it's
you'll have the time of your life